of the bachelor's so [ __ ] up i mean
they they found the girl this time this
girl
has been on the bachelor then she was on
bachelor in paradise
it's her fifth time on the bachelor show
this poor guy
he hasn't had any time alone with her to
talk to her he finally sits down
so he says to her i got to tell you when
i saw that you were the bachelorette
it made me want to come here and pursue
you
and she goes oh is that right that's so
wonderful
what did you like about me so he says
well i
saw you and i thought you were quite
attractive
so i decided to to apply to come on the
show and
and wait a second she go i gotta tell
you
most guys say they admire my courage or
they admire my fortitude
drive she goes you're superficial boom
you're out of here and i'm saying to
myself he's the only
guy who's telling the truth so what made
you want to be on here for me
first of all you're obviously absolutely
gorgeous
but other than that to be honest with
you i don't know really anything about
you i know that you're you know
from sacramento are you born and raised
or
wait so you said you knew that i was a
bachelorette
and you wanted to sign up mm-hmm but you
don't know anything about me
i don't i don't know you obviously don't
know you on a personal level and don't
know your history
uh um you're just you're just so
beautiful and i wanted to get to know
you
is there any other thing that made you
want to come on because for me
um i don't have a specific answer for
you and that is honest by the way
yeah he's no bullshitter
there's a lot of guys here that say they
like my drive or they like what i have
to offer
they like that i stood up for myself i
mean just anything
other than my life i already know that
no of course but they didn't know that
they didn't know that prior to coming on
the show which is they didn't know that
pirates are coming on the show because a
lot of them have
that's like when you go to a bar think
about what he said i walk into a bar i
saw you you were attractive
so i went over to see if there was more
there that's all he's saying
i wanted to get to know you yeah he
didn't walk up there and go
by the way i have to tell you i came
over here because i love your drive
i see your energy i mean that's [ __ ]
there was one guy on there this guy
chasing
every other word he says is like count
how many times he says like fred you got
that little bell sound effect
every time he says light just hit the
bell i want to know
like why you are the way you are tell me
about that yeah so when i was younger
um like i was like kind of like bullied
a little bit
and like i like got killed for being
like short
really yeah look at you now and burn on
them
i know right it's like looking back i
was kind of like a hermit crab
like i like stayed in and like like play
video games and i was never like the guy
that you see today
right yeah it was really great to open
up to
claire and like have her listen to me it
just flowed so natural like it just felt
like i've known her for a long time
and i think she really liked that i can
be vulnerable and i could put myself in
a position to like open my heart
i just felt like electricity was kind of
going through my body i mean you can't
even like
see my arms with like i had the
goosebumps afterwards and
i mean that moment we just had that was
something that you
would read in a book like in a fairy
tale you couldn't even keep up with
those likes
no they were coming so fast fred missed
a couple
but the bachelor this season is good
because they had to lock all these like
they don't even get to get out of their
house they're all in quarantine together
and there's no like special dates and
getting on helicopters
and going in limos no foreign countries
all that stuff they used to do
all out yeah now it's like hey you want
to go on a date yeah
you want to go on a date let's go over
to the pool over here
is it a date it's a great season best
season yet
most shocking season as chris harrison
says
i love chris harrison never gives these
people any decent advice he just
watches him make a mess he goes man
you're a mess